we are approaching now the five-year
Mark of one October the night 58 people
died in a mass shooting at around 91
Harvest Festival in front of Mandalay
Bay the death toll would climb to 60. so
the threads of one October really kind
of stretch everywhere you might have
known someone who's at the concert a
friend of a friend who survived maybe a
neighbor who never made it home as John
langler reports sometimes those threads
tie each other together in unexpected
places
to carry those stories with you taniel
Pereira is used to the stories stories
of trauma loss grief and pain she runs
the Vegas strong resiliency Center the
baggage that comes along with what I do
you know it can be a heavy weight so
Pereira runs a lot it's kind of where I
do my self-reflection and and process
things so do her children they're three
of the fastest young runners in Las
Vegas and those friendships are really
strong Christine Jeanette helps push
pereira's teenagers to go even faster
doesn't just try to be their biggest
cheerleader she's been their coach in
one form or another since Emily was in
sixth grade is it how she coaches you is
it is it uh she doesn't put up with
nonsense
right here at the downtown healing
Garden the stories of what October live
on forever about five years ago Pereira
learned her children's own coach was one
of thousands with the story of her own I
was helping a Survivor with something
Jeanette as it turns out was there I
shared the story of my husband and I
being survivors or survivors of that
night and what we went through the Route
91 Country Music Festival I discovered
that she was actually my child's teacher
it was unexpected but appropriate she
had so many stories she probably had
heard at this point and that now I knew
I had a connection and somebody that I
could reach out to Jeanette and her
husband were among the thousands who
escaped the one October shooting I'm
trying not to let what happened five
years ago Define who I am her strength
and compassion comes from her students
Jeanette is the driving force behind the
angel wings project at Cadwallader
Middle School my students I tell them
all the time they help me heal so does
the simple Act of running One Foot In
Front of the other that night we didn't
have a chance to decide whether or not
we were going to run
and this is her way of taking her power
back at last year's Vegas drawing 5K
Pereira and her children were among the
fastest Jeanette was there as I crossed
that Finish Line she put that medal
around me like it just felt like things
came uh full circle as Jeanette marks
five years since the night that changed
her life she is determined not to run
from the emotions anymore
her finish line is the downtown healing
Garden a place she's never been I just
don't know quite why I haven't been down
and so this year is going to be my year
it has to be John langler eight news now